this is the shit ball came out the shit
that was the first film but this is uh
quickly satisfied so it starts off like
there's Decepticons all over the world
and we have to find a boom that crane
thing will time transform our plans okay
kids our truck is there and he's like
why and Optimus Prime god damn it's so
good see Optimus Prime again not only
that there's all new Transformers down
there as well like size-wise boy I think
only has two lines our CEO I think only
has one line and child who I don't think
every times at all that's pretty weak
but the twins are there and they're
hilarious
you're gonna who's easy to do that I
have no idea what they're saying Todd
akin from before he's going off the
college as your friend says save up me
to you of me now you say you love me oh
you say you love me let's just
compromise the same ripoff a whole
school so the skit comes across another
kid who thinks the Transformers are real
and I like wait a minute how can they
don't think the real the hell like this
huge battle the opening but it's okay
because it turns out that's all covered
up yeah the first film to that huge epic
battle in the city where you know
thousands of people were watching yeah
that's that's all covered up pretty late
but the Decepticons words are right
Megatron and turns out he's being
controlled by the evil fallen blue what
a secret language of the kid's head so
the kids like so the evil Decepticons
want to get what's in his head something
something that's really pretty
Decepticon to open his mind
oh he's not real Decepticon it's like a
college girl it's a distance much
wantonness brand comes to save the day
he battles Megatron hmm come on come on
come on and all the sides that Megatron
kills after this prime right that's
right Megatron kills Optimus Prime Oh
I'm just like you something if you side
then I remember we said a long time ago
and I quote I died for yours
you sure did prime for the sins of us
all so they're going to find this other
transformer clutch a fire and Jeff is
friggin cool
he's like a transformer they were all
crotchety old assholes and that kicked
ass major asset so Jetfire is like we
have to stop the fallin from creating
this pyramid that will destroy the son
of us create a bunch of other
transformers let's ruin the world some
shit like that who cares
shit blows up boom boom boom so the ball
and get on all the TVs in the world and
they're like head over the kid oh you're
dog meat I'll get you next time gadget
and a little beam on the water like holy
shit aliens are real and the government
is like it's okay we'll cover it up okay
don't I get to the pyramids where
apparently this machine can bring
Optimus Prime back to life and this
super big kick-ass my tripods up it's
like five transformers in one holy shit
it's so cool so I'm like oh my god what
the hell is this thing gonna do
and he's only on the screen for like two
minutes week so we got two people firing
in the desert and firing in the desert
and then firing in the desert but then
the kid dies oh I guess not today but
then the kid goes to robot heaven I'm
totally not kidding robot heaven where
all the other primes are there and they
give him back his life week so the kid
comes back to Lightning tries to use the
machine to bring back Optimus welding
fire in the desert so the kid uses a
machine returnees Prime
I died for your sins so you sure he did
but then the Fallen come and take
control the machine they're gonna use it
to blast out the Sun so they all
continued everyone the legend fires like
take my parts Optimus I owned an
annoying and Altemus bride says ok and
brought me comes super out the
motherfucking prime he kicks ass more
very drastic so he goes up against the
Fallen and Megatron and it's over in
like a minute
it's like done week so yeah the climax
is a bit of a cock tease but aside from
that it was great thumbs up 5 stars
great is adequately satisfying movie of
all time and I liked it too I'm a
nostalgia critic I remember it so you
don't have to do did he just do my head